Plan for today.
Oops, this is the wrong docker.
We're pretty close to having like a
stable uh pre-alpha
I'm thinking we get our sweeps working
today. Oops.
Seriously, Docker.
There a couple things I want to look up
real quick. You know
Oh,
cool. This thing just runs.
Hit N.
Page up. page down.
systems, metrics.
Interesting.
I mean, you don't really have any way to
do um
This is like a nice quick thing, I
guess, for the latest run.
Can you have multiple runs on this thing
or is it single run?
I mean, we are going to have
constellation anyways for multi-run,
right?
Maybe that's what we should get working.
The only problem with constellation,
right, is it's a visual interface.
No, I think we should still get
constellation working. That'll then
we'll have like the full end to end end
of it, which will be nice.
And then we'll honestly though this one
be elite thing is
for just like having a couple graphs of
the latest run is pretty solid and the
fact it works offline is very very nice.
Yeah, I'd say that's very very nice.
Cool that they have it.
Oh yeah, let me get one other thing real
quick.
Yeah, let's see if we can just really
crank on um on the end to end today.
Yeah, I need start time first. It's
fine.
Now let's see. Does this exit cleanly or
not
does not exit cleanly. So we got to fix
that.
So what we're going to do is we're going
to make a close method
do like this.
Close.
train.
We can just do void close.
Why is it doing this? Wait. Yeah, we
don't need these brackets.
That does not seem correct to me. It
should not have a dot close.
Hover vec is vec.
So create environments returns vec.
Hey, how's it going? Going pretty well.
Just started. We're going to try to get
um local hyper pram sweeps running super
super fast right now.
sample objects full
static vec.
Oh yeah, we don't even have to do um
and binding
and binding.h.
All right, we don't have back anymore.
Perfect.
So now what we just have to do is we
just add static back wait static back
close
This is fine. We can Oops. Do we free
the environment? No, we do not free end.
We free ends.
And then everything else also
has to get freed.
I actually need to see how do you create
a CUDA host. Alec, I don't know how you
do this.
Wait, wait. We have to stop all the
threads, don't we?
I forget it. What's the saying? Is it
like P kill? No.
Yeah. See, this is just not going to
work is the problem.
I think the answer to this is like it's
going to have to get redesigned a little
bit, right?
Let's not use Opus. Don't be tempted
here. We have to do this correctly.
Do we have atomics in here? No, we do
not have atomics in here. So, we can't
do this.
We can put it in static threading.
running SPS. No, we have a lot of SPS
now. I'm going to try to make it
gracefully shut down and like make sure
we're not leaking stuff so that we can
uh get sweeps running. I'd really like
to have, you know, if we can see 10
experiments of breakout running per
minute, that'd be awesome.
I might even be able to test this with
Pong and get like, you know, 20 30
experiments per minute.
effect of each hyper. Yes. So that's
constellation.
Um, the goal of that that visualizer,
it's the same thing that's still going
into the release.
I guess here's what we can do.
This is what we can do. So that we can
make this one wallpro
Wait, we can just return. I'm dumb.
Why? Don't be stupid.
Good luck, Phen. I love your content.
Thank you. Yeah, it's a lot of just like
low-level fiddling as it turns out
because most of RL is just bottlenecked
by systems, not anything else.
There is actual algorithmic work to be
done, but I mean, it's way way easier
when stuff is fast and we're mostly
bottlenecked by stuff just being slow.
I'll have to see if they fight over this
resource.
we have to signal
all the threads to stop.
Yes.
So then we join
Okay. So now we free
we free the ends
buffer stage threads
threading
uh buffer and start and count. So
everything gets freed here.
Then we need the CUDA breeze.
Oh, the streams.
Yeah, we need to How do we close
streams?
Vec streams.
How does this work?
Oh, no way. Pie torch is responsible for
this.
We can ignore the streams. I think
Puffarel torch streams of buff.
Oh, so these don't get used. Wait, no,
they do get used. streams of I
It's a little weird because we have like
this mixed
C++ jank. But I think that this end
close should be good.
And then all we need to do
close
This is probably going to be one of the
places where I do need to ask Claude
because this is
not
just freaking C++ hell here, right?
Weights for sure. No, no, because
weights are just allocated with zeros.
Definitely want the startup and tear
down time to be very fast.
Okay, we didn't lose any perf, it looks
like. Good.
Let me just try renaming in case it's
conflicting.
Jess.
We uh we got this thing to close
cleanly, it seems.
What to close uh the environments to
close cleanly. We're trying to get stuff
cleaned up so we can run sweeps.
Many agents who are good at something
work together.
Well, the LLM version of it is
completely [ __ ] stupid.
Um, and
you can have specialist agents for
stuff. It makes more sense in RL,
frankly. But then the whole work
together part, it really depends on the
problem. It's not something that you
just like throw out as a general concept
and immediately have transform
everything or whatever.
multiGPU. Let's get single GPU sweeps
first. All right.
I'm trying to think how I want to go
about this. I think we can just fry
That we can totally set up, right? Let's
do that.
Okay.
It's a sweep
saying hyper
train mini batches
which is no longer a hyper
gone.
But this should be replay ratio.
So, here's something cool that we
haven't thought about, guys.
I actually think it's possible that we
solve breakout substantially faster than
7 seconds now. Um, and the reason is
we have configs that used to not be
computationally efficient that are
computationally efficient now.
So, let me explain what I mean by that,
right? It used to be that if you ran at
um batch size
2048, for instance, it's the exact same
speed as running at batch size 1024
because you didn't have it optimized,
right? So, basically everything's
dominated by overhead. Uh which means
you'd always just run big batch size.
And this is one of the cheats that I had
in Puffer. people said, "Well, okay,
we're just going to run everything at
big batch size then until we make stuff
faster." Now, we've made stuff faster,
so you actually can get benefit from
going smaller. It took us waiting
through nine layers uh nine levels of
CUDA,
but we've done it. So, hopefully that
should get us uh some interesting new
results, qualitatively
interesting new results.
Mini batch size must be greater than
equal to horizon 32 times total agents
which it is
less than equal
that
83.
So probably here the uh we have like
some policy sweep stuff.
So what we have policy gets hidden size
numbum layers
and expansion factor.
Well, that's interesting. It managed to
go find a very, very slow config.
Max cost me go down to 30 now because
everything's so fast. No need to wait
longer than 30 seconds for a run of
something as simple as breakout.
It was the old soda.
Okay,
so now this should time out after 30
seconds, right?
So this trained the full minute and 4
seconds which is not ideal.
And then we error on this which is
total agents
Okay, so there should not be a 4096 in
here unless it's the mini batch.
Total agents, no buffers.
Oh, it is the mini batch size of 4096.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, it looks like the input size got
messed up, right?
H.
Yeah, the input size is messed up here.
Hang on. We have
Where's hidden size? Horizon.
Well, I see it on the default here for
the hidden size of mining.
Is it not getting passed? I wonder.
Now I see hidden size here. Hyper's
hidden size.
I guess we can probably see it from um
from here.
And where is it?
There.
Just need to get all the hyper
combinations nice and stable so we can
sweep. I mean it should realistically it
should be very very fast. Uh what's this
max cost?
we end up with a 3se secondond breakout
solve.
How about how will we celebrate the 5k
puffer star party? Y'all got to start
puffer so we get to 5k. I don't know. I
could come up with something cool to do.
5K is a really awesome milestone.
There's all sorts of cool stuff I could
do to be honest. It's just like
there is so much work to be left on
Puffer 4 and I know that I have a couple
contracts that we're starting pretty
soon. Uh I've kind of been able to do
more work on this than I was going to be
able to because
uh both of those contracts got delayed a
couple weeks. But like when I start
those, I'm going to have even less time
to be on the core dev for a bit. So I've
just wanted to really get something as
close to stable as possible before I
start on all that stuff.
I mean, it's so much work. It's just so
so so much work.
I do have a couple things I want to do
though with Puffer the next time that
things are in like a good spot and we
want some new environments or, you know,
we want some new stuff to look at. I got
a couple cool ideas.
Oh, it's in the create error. Wait, the
create errors?
Really?
It errors when we pass different hidden
size. Really?
Oh, it's the expansion factor. I see it.
Yeah, I see it.
I think we're just not going to do
expansion factor for now, right?
to 1.6 mil permn net training 3 mil SPS.
Oh yeah, we got to actually we got to
fix the SPS health though.
It's a little weird with the replay
ratio being able to go under one.
Well, sweeps look like they
That's pretty cool.
Yeah, this just runs
cool.
We also have this whole frame skip
thingy.
you need CJ JSON as well. That's no big
deal, though. Okay, let's just let's do
this. I'm going to go grab myself a mug
of tea. Let me commit this. And uh we're
going to get set up on my local. We're
get constellation set up.
What? Get puff or leia. Get puff.
If you haven't seen constellation
before, it will be very, very cool. It's
essentially, it's this pure C uh really
snazzy rendered UI for hyperparam
sweeps. I spent a little bit of extra
time making it look pretty. Uh, and I
want to see if we can get data from
Puffer 4 into constellation because I
think it's going to be really sweet.
Like, let's say that we set a 10-second
timeout or a 5second timeout on breakout
experiments or on pong experiments
rather. Like, that means we can collect
10 to 20 experiments per minute of Pong.
So, that's really sweet. Uh, I got to
use the restroom real quick. I got to
grab myself a mug of tea and then we are
going to go and see if we can get that
set up. I'll be right back.
Okay.
Okay. Now I will show off the cool
thing. I shall show you the cool thing.
JSON
dot C.
What's the license on this? Do whatever
you want. Very nice.
And Ray Gooey
We need to get these included as well.
Install
single file header only. Regui C
source.
Is there a C?
Hey, there's no C, right?
Yeah, we're definitely going to need Ray
camera.
I didn't like um Whoops. I didn't bother
like setting all the build stuff up
for this.
There we go.
Lump.
Why is it have Buru? Why does it have
Buru by default?
Okay, now hopefully we have
constellation. Let's see.
oh no. You know what? I know what this
is.
I know what this is. This is fine. This
is why you should write your stuff
header only.
Um, this is why you should write your
stuff header only.
Because otherwise people have to
remember to do this crap
And that's super annoying.
Oh, cuz you're dumb. This is why. It's
just cuz you're dumb. It's that easy.
There you go.
And then you have to give it a file,
right?
Proper lib ocean constellation
default.json.
I don't know if I have that JSON file
somewhere.
puffer logger. Close right
right here.
Return all logs.
Okay.
And then you have logger close and model
path. Model path is pop close
uh which does not return a correct path
at the moment. So we need to fix that
uh to explain what's going on here. Let
me do that briefly.
So the idea of constellation, it's an
aggregate run viewer, right? So you can
you uh grab a whole bunch of runs, you
post-process them, you load them into
constellation, and it gives you a bunch
of stats and visuals. Technically, I
suppose you could use it sort of for
single runs as well if you really wanted
to. I could experiment with that. Um
yeah, I could experiment with that. But
regardless,
uh, we just have to figure out why stuff
is not saving.
Okay, so this doesn't have the model in
it for some reason.
I think what we should do is I put this
breakpoint up here. We should see why
it's not saving.
India, hello chief puffing officer.
Yeah,
this amusing.
Yeah, race sounds really awesome.
Number of samples used for training.
Why is there no documentation of example
commands to get started? Because there's
an entire website for you, my guy.
There is an entire website for you right
here. It's linked on the readme.
You have an entire website with docs.
Here are all the cheat commands, right?
All the cheat sheet commands. Here a
whole bunch of examples for you. Here's
a little bit about the design of the
library. And here's a detailed tutorial
on how to write your own environment.
All our documentation is hosted at
puffer.a. I think that's pretty clear,
right?
What is the ratio of your portrait
video? There's no specific ratio. It's
just it's just um it's a standard video
format, but then it's clipped, right?
Like I just clip the video to fit myself
on the screen.
Like I can do this, right?
I can also do like this,
you know.
I considered having our docs be um like
mirrored to the main page, but that's
really annoying because then I have to
write our docs to MD or
I have to write our docs to MD and our
docs are not in markdown. Our docs are
HTML.
I don't know why GitHub doesn't just
render an HTML for your docs file. It
would be so much easier.
I remember that one time they had the um
they had that injection bug where you
could basically theme your GitHub
homepage however you wanted.
concerning amount of coffee.
This is tea with one tea bag. It's just
weak tea.
I actually don't really have that much
caffeine these days.
There were several years of my life
where it was like four energy drinks a
day. I remember in high school there
would be days where I'd been up for the
last like 30 hours um where I would sit
down for lunch unironically with six to
eight shots of espresso just to get
through the day. I don't do that crap
anymore. I sleep and I don't have that
much coffee or uh that much coffee
anymore. I have some
Uh, we're just not saving our model, are
we?
health norl. Yeah. Oh, I'm in good shape
now.
I did um a couple weeks ago I did a uh
20 minute three mile
uh a little earlier
couple two three months ago I got up to
a four plate dead I got back up to a
four plate deadlift only weighing 172
pounds or so self.
Exercise is very important.
I'm doing a little bit less exercise now
than I normally do. Um, but I mean, I'm
still training hard three times a week
for like two hours.
Actually, this is a this is a cloud
thing. This is 100% a claw thing.
Actually, I'm sure it has these. What
the hell's wrong with this?
Yeah. Hey, if every time I go to use it,
I see it's stupid, then it's like that's
good, right?
I mean, you're the one who keeps
bringing up feed in my stream,
so I don't know what that says.
Yeah, this is [ __ ] here.
This is like giga [ __ ]
safe tensors to make sharing models
viable.
Does that work cross compatible with So
I hate adding dependencies. Does it work
cross-co compatible with lib torch and
um torch's python API because this is
like a pure meta [ __ ] the fact that
their save function does not work
between C++ and Python.
check to make sure. I mean, I don't know
if it's a make sure. I doubt it is.
Like, this is just torch purely screwing
up. I think what I'm going to probably
do is I'm going to finish Puffer 4 in
Q1.
We're going to have a few months worth
of client work plus research on Puffer
5, which is like pure algorithmic.
And then probably by puffer six, I think
it's going to be time to delete
PieTorch.
Oh, we'll see how Tiny does, but I don't
see Tiny replacing what I'm doing unless
they go with a um unless they get a
lower level interface.
It's the wrong level of abstraction.
Tiny grat is very very good and I think
it's probably the best uh for pure
Python,
but you need lower level.
Oh, you're just doing it in the wrong
order, you dummy.
constellation.py.
Okay, so this is the shitty version,
right?
We do not have past in here. That is
bad.
It will test. Uh, I think that I just
got it to save at least the dictionary
weights. I think I can probably just
write a few lines of code and not add
the dependency.
I'm really sick of PyTorch, though. I'm
sick of Pybind. I'm sick of PyTorch. I'm
sick of Python. I'm sick of C++.
It's really incredible to me how many of
the vast majority of the like
innovations in
abstraction, you know, like how to like
higher level stuff are just lies in the
modern era.
There are two ways to make things
simple, right? is to work very hard or
to lie. And I mean, most of the stuff
that I'm seeing in torch and whatnot,
it's you just lie cuz you're losing all
this performance. You're losing all this
flexibility. Sometimes you're even
making stuff more complicated than doing
it just the fast, simple way.
It's really sad.
Python with Vim.
What do you mean Python with Vim?
There's a tiny amount of Python in this
project because researchers want Python
binds. It's mostly C, C++, CUDA.
became I mean I don't blame him. It's
just like screw this [ __ ] I'm out is
what that is.
Okay. Why do we not have cost in our
data
in the sense of security
you shouldn't be loading randomass
models.
What are you making? I developed puffer
liib. This is the highest performance
reinforcement learning library out
there. Um, you can take a look at some
of our environments.
We do algorithms research. We do new
infrastructure,
low-level engineering,
environment and simulation creation.
It's all open source
and I just stream all of my development
on this. I'm a researcher. I've been
doing this type of stuff for a decade.
I run a small private research lab
around this,
but since all our core stuff is open
source, I get to stream it
and it's fun.
I don't know. When I started this, I
kind of figured, well, there aren't
really many watch cutting edge research
being done live streams, so that sounds
like a cool thing to do.
Here's the JSON file.
self.path
args of data.
This
That's cool. Yeah,
you're using Linux.
Um, everybody, uh, everybody who's doing
serious scientific computing is using
Linux.
It's just there. There's no way around
that.
You'll just waste a lot of time on dumb
things otherwise.
I think all the rest of these are fine.
This one no longer exist. This is replay
ratio
and then this is
total agents.
Let's just generate ourselves a few
runs. Do you code in C++ when I have to?
It's a terrible language.
Unfortunately, we have a lot of it in um
in here because of the torch APIs in
C++.
I don't even want to look at how much
stuff we have in here.
Yeah, I don't know. We probably have
four or 5,000 lines worth of C++ at the
moment. I wish we did not have.
We have like 50,000 lines of C.
C is so much nicer.
I think eventually we will strip out all
of the C++ and just replace it with nice
simple C.
We'll probably keep the Python bindings,
but we'll have very very thin Python
bindings.
I'm very I'm just happy when I get to be
writing say
like things are just simple and work
somehow that says it's running at 20
million SPS.
I don't trust that. But cool.
Helix.
What's Helix?
Oh, the editor. I don't really need an
editor.
Yeah. Rust
or terminal. Oh, okay. At least it's an
app.
I mean, like, this looks fine, but
do I really have any need for this?
I probably should take a little bit of
time um at some point to get basic I
probably should take a little bit of
time to have basic stuff like this
either in my BIM config or whatever
considering that
um I've decided that most of the AI crap
is just not good. it would be better to
get more out of my existing tools.
It's a little irritating because it's
like
on one hand
a lot of the editor tools it's it's
built to like let you manage large
redundant code bases, but you shouldn't
have large redundant code bases. Of
course, with this version of Puffer, we
kind of now have a unavoidably large and
redundant codebase because of Torch.
So, yeah, built-in LSP isn't builtin LSP
is nice. So, the one thing that I uh I
absolutely need, at least until it stops
being supported, uh there's a plugin for
Super Maven for this. So, Super Maven is
really really stupid AI tab complete.
So, if I like start typing, it's really
stupid AI tab complete, but the model
just runs really fast.
That's pretty much all I need is I need
um
like some really stupid model that runs
really fast for tab complete.
like definitely sub 250 ms, ideally
faster.
I'm a little concerned with this sweep
that we're not finding good hypers.
That's kind of odd.
Well, let's see if I can run cache data.
Perplexity must be less than num
samples, which is one.
Why is num samples one?
Uh because if you get cut off, you don't
log rage.
close, we should do
log cost.
Is that AI model free? Uh, it's no
longer supported, unfortunately. So, it
was from Super Maven and then Cursor
bought Super Maven and then Cursor was
going to shut down the old Super Maven
stuff and then all of the users bitched
a whole bunch. So, they said, "All
right, you know what? We'll uh we'll
leave it on." So,
we still have the model for now. New
here? What are you building? I developed
Puffer. Puffer is the highest
performance RL library. You can check
out a lot of these demos on puffer.ai.
We have all sorts of agents that run in
your browser. Think like tiny superhuman
models for specific tasks that are
trained on decades or millennia worth of
simulated game data or not just games.
We've got drones, we've got driving,
pretty much any types of sims.
And I stream all of my research.
I don't know why this is like this.
Write logs.
Oh, I see.
So then this should be fine if I just do
log cost. Should it not
very silly
use ray for the sims? Ray is simply for
rendering the simulations. It's not for
the actual logic for the most part.
I mean sometimes we use some of their
math functions for convenience, but
their math functions are like a few
lines if you want to implement them.
Hey Finn, we've put some more details
about our unis.
Yeah, so this is you got to keep
reminding me about that because
otherwise I will forget. But I did agree
to do that and I will prepare uh I will
prepare a talk for it. Let me go update
Discord so I can go see what that is.
Uh Finn is the one of the two people who
made the uh the drone environment by the
way that I just showed on the website.
probably the best um standalone
environment PR we've gotten
21st
time sl the time zones. What is the
21st? 21st is a Saturday. I will be free
all day on a Saturday.
Uh I am on Eastern time.
Oh jeez. This is going to be UK, isn't
it?
GMT is UK, right?
Or am I stupid?
Yes.
Okay. So, let's say that I'm free from
9:00 a.m.
I'll write this down.
5:00 p.m. is noon ESP.
Let's say
Leaving to code. I hope you enjoy
coding.
I normally do.
I'd really like to be fighting with
torch way less,
but I normally do enjoy my work. I think
it's just this type of stuff burns me
out very very quickly. Well, not this.
This is easy ass Python. Um, most of my
stream is just fighting all sorts of
low-level info with torch in their C++
code.
Replexity must be less than n samples.
Okay. Well, we're going to just go look
at what we have because presumably this
is just like bad data.
Mute t.
Okay,
that's fine. All right.
Let's see if we can just go from here,
right?
Oh, nothing
as far as puffer tank.
T new one not found in end. Okay. Yeah,
that's a little bit annoying, isn't it?
So, we need to just fake some data, I
guess, until we um until Artis works.
0 time size.
Yeah,
we can try this.
don't need Claude. You know, I used
Claude for a few weeks. It's just bad.
It's really bad.
Like, I don't feel too stupid about it
because the codebase I was using it on
was unavoidably [ __ ] right? like I
inherited all the garbage from torch
and as a result a lot of the code is
very redundant.
I definitely overused it a bit even then
though and like
the model is very very dumb.
I still think it's okay to use it for
very deterministic refactor ops.
I think that there's a place for it, but
this whole zeitgeist around it is
completely unjustified.
What's this supposed to be? Two list
to row plus size.
compute tick. Ah, I see.
Let's just give it um
let's just give it this
object of type nd array is not JS on
list.
How do we still have um how do we still
have this in
looks fine to me? Did I just mess up the
Hang on.
test data.
Right.
This is just not saving correctly.
There we go. So, now we copy it.
Now we SCP.
And now we do. Oh, no. No. Now we copy
it to the right directory.
Interesting. Well, I'm use the restroom
real quick. I'm going to get a refill on
my tea and uh we'll figure this out. I
mean, the goal for today is basically to
get uh training data from sweeps loaded
into constellation and start iterating
on the actual experiment loop. you know,
we start to get the full end to end
going.
Don't use it to implement PO. Holy.
Yeah, that will be a total disaster. I
actually wouldn't be surprised if it
makes something work, but like
you will get better code. Just go copy
paste clean RL. Like it's trained on
clean RL.
You'll do better just by copy pasting
All right,
I'll be right back.
Welcome to Florida. I just go uh look
out the window and there's just a bobcat
there looking at me like, "Hey, how's it
going?
Wait, why is this?
Huh?
What the What did I do?
Okay, so the X min and maxes are bad,
right?
And how are we still going to seg volta
on this? Huh?
I ran cache. I copied this.
Like how are we still going to seg?
Yeah. Why are the mins and maxes like
this?
They shouldn't be.
You know what? I bet it's cashing
stupid.
Cash.
I bet it's this.
Is it the TTF?
Oh, it's the freaking TTF, isn't it?
Wait. Resources shared.
There we go.
I don't see it on here as the problem.
This weird
Well, this does not look anywhere near
as snazz as it looks when you have a
bunch of data loaded incorrectly.
Believe you me
doesn't show up here.
That's very weird.
check Discord.
Let me see. Hey, Spencer, we're hooking
up Constellation or attempting to. So,
we're getting close to having some sort
of end to end.
Oo,
that's a good model. I don't know why
it's not log linear, right? It actually
does level out.
Unsweet because speed. Yeah.
And we got some chest.
I mean, that's a very good starting
point for this, I would say.
It doesn't seem log linear in compute,
though, right? Like towards the end,
that's like that's actually leveling out
fully.
Okay. I mean, solid progress there.
Did you say something, by the way, that
you had the drive ends
There's definitely some jank in 40 we're
going to have to fix before we can get
everything onto it.
It goes to zero. Yeah, I don't know if
it's the kernels or if it's Bflat. Um,
there are definitely some instabilities.
I will say
I'm trying to see if we can get sweeps
working. Like if we can get the whole
end to end sweet plus constellation
thing working on even just on breakout
then my hope is that we can sort of
crowdsource a little bit. You know if I
can make the setup easy we can have um
some of our contributors fig uh fiddle
with some of the individual
environments.
I think that there's also likely to just
be some numerical stuff that needs to be
improved in both the kernels and bloat.
It's very cool though.
This is very cool.
Uh those are individual experiments that
you're seeing on Palm.
down sample zero should be keep the
whole trajectory All right.
Mini batch size is less than horizon.
Okay.
point.
It's a bunch of experiments. They're not
doing well though.
And we owe him. So that means
probably something is not getting freed
correctly.
Well, we have it way too few time steps.
So, let's do this.
slow and steady.
Is it the same graphs?
You both sent me the same graphs. Yeah,
it's very cool.
It's very cool.
Possibly we need to constrain this to
play with this a little bit.
Okay, let's let's figure out what we can
what can we constrain a little bit here.
Go do like this.
Two,
seven,
four, two, six.
Hang on. Something is wrong that this is
only getting to like -14 or whatever.
Uh this is usable data for constellation
at the very least.
Yeah, that's actually sweeping stuff.
Cool.
Interesting. So, we're not seeing Oh,
no. They are. They're very faint up top.
And we have nowhere near as many points
as we should have, I would think.
Yeah. Look at all these. We're supposed
to have lots of these points.
We're not seeing them for some reason.
Am
I being done with the shader? I don't
think so.
No,
I only see four points,
but there a bunch of points right here.
Cost
agent steps
earth.
Is it getting filtered somehow? It
shouldn't be.
I definitely shouldn't be getting
filtered.
Let's see if we can figure out why this
is getting uh screwed up the way it is.
We got 5 mil SPS on Soabon. Soon's a
very nice environment.
Sounds good.
20 points.
That look right?
1 2
5 6 7
Yeah, there are a lot of points here.
That should be
I don't see these points though. So like
1.6
and 16. And where is this point?
I've not looked at this code in a few
months.
Ah, negative.
Somehow this got transformed negative.
Something screwy here, man. Something's
very screwy.
I don't see the point that's supposed to
be out here.
Is my two pix function wrong? I don't
understand.
I mean this is definitely wrong. So, how
is this getting converted?
Let's see if we can just like set a
break point to px.
Oh, actually, hang on. Is this
hyper
the way to automate Wait,
I feel better if the ELO game was not
plateauing.
No idea if it's not good enough for
selfplay output. Yeah. So, this is why
you need like benchmark M for this. Want
to figure out if there's way to automate
easy plug in a scripted opponent. Yeah.
So, there are environments for which you
can do that, right? But like chess, the
scripted opponents are pretty like
pretty complex and heavy.
Okay, that looks like a nice point,
right?
Oh, is this going to end up being neg?
Is this what's happening? Hang on.
Y I
Z. Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, it's negative.
Not upside down, right? like
agent with a way to figure out how to
abuse it.
Yeah. So, I mean it's possible that
there are games where this is not the
case, but it's kind of difficult to
think of any.
It would have to be like basically the
only thing I could think of is
um you'd have to have a
like an imperfect information game where
the information is a big advantage so
that your scripted opponent can just
cheat. That's basically the only way I
can think of doing it.
pretty sure that this is supposed to
Okay.
There it is.
Genuine bug in constellation.
It's embarrassing.
Well, we're definitely now knowing that
going to have to have some test data for
this.
Yeah.
All right. Well, we'll fiddle with this,
but this is like a good start.
So, I think with that we can go back to
figuring out how to actually get this
thing to sweep correctly.
Um,
see if within a few experiments this
learns anything usable.
And then we can also check Kyouung's
breakout sweeps for comparison. There's
a lot we can do here.
Okay,
we are getting reasonable stuff now.
Yeah, that's reasonable stuff.
we are getting like runs that are
sensible. We'll have to tune this. I
think the next big issue is going to be
the um
the GPU me. Right. Let's see if this OM
over time. I'm going to use the
restroom. I'm going to let this do some
experiments. Um and I'll see if this OM
Okay. Yeah, that's definitely leaking
memory.
That's definitely leaking memory.
Yep. Okay. So, it's just leaking all the
me. Let's see. Um,
that's the main thing that we fix. We
got to fix that and clean some stuff up.
samples collected.
This is fair.
We'll just have a standard config for
it.
Okay. Well, this is okay.
Again, total brain damage.
Like why the hell would you put that in
the Python code?
Oh, I'm dumb. It isn't the That is the
C++ code. Okay. me big dumb wall.
It's a bigger network. If it goes back
down, we're good.
std bad Alec
on save checkpoint.
Funny. It's like um the utilization is a
very bad um a bad metric. It's actually
only at 100 watts.
Of
course, if you give it a bigger network,
it'll saturate a bit more.
800k. 800K at 7 mil SPS. It's pretty
crazy.
Yes. So, this is definitely broken
because look at this. This is a 44k
parameter network
and we're at 5800 MB.
Why is your GPU not maxed out when
training?
Like, why is it not at literally 100 and
max wattage?
This is the fastest RM RL implementation
out there, and it's still nowhere near
max what the hardware can do.
It's very very tough to optimize small
networks.
What do you mean? And not
intermittently. It's sitting at 90. It's
always being used. Like the utilization
is very high. But like this number lies.
This number does not mean your workload
is effective. This just means that
you're not literally letting the GPU sit
idle doing nothing. It can still be
doing stuff very inefficiently.
We can just do Here. Let's do it this
way.
Do this. Do this.
and I really hate to.
It's just so annoying.
somehow better than Jacks.
I Google engineers, I swear.
So, like
Meta is the company that just does your
bog standard big enterprise engineering
and does it badly like you would expect.
Google's the company that does your big
enterprise engineering, but then they
think that they're very clever. So, they
come up with all sorts of new ways to
make stuff [ __ ] So, torches basically
[ __ ] in the standard way that you expect
of big enterprise software. Like, you at
least know what you're getting. Jacks,
you have to just twist your brain into
this specific form of dementia that
occupies Google engineers.
I don't even know what the hell with
that thing.
I'm basically sick of dealing with torch
at this point though.
Okay,
this is fine for testing.
If this at least works, then what we'll
be able to do is we'll be able to like
go through and see what it is actually
necessary.
Yeah, this dumb [ __ ] thing. It's the
exact same.
The only thing that can be this big is
the graphs.
Yeah, this is just not fun.
Not fun at all.
What is this stuff he posts? Like, what
is this, man?
Okay,
that could be it.
Increase the number of M's and ends up
stuttering and making the SPS
Well, you can't just infinitely increase
num ms, mana
at somewhere. At some point, you're
bandwidth bound.
Like, go just for fun, go do the back of
the envelope math for the number of
flops that a network would take.
Estimate one flop per parameter, right?
And then the number of flops your GPU is
technically capable of. And you'll see
it's like we're not even close. All
right. You're mostly memory bound.
That said, you should be able to be
training at millions of steps per
second. No problem.
That's just saving the mele ID. That's
fine.
Let's try cud. Let's try the uh this
thing now with cudigraphs.
You want to have zero leaked memory.
Damn it.
I just have no interest in dealing with
um
torches
crap wrappers
for this
device index. Great. So now it's going
to be GPU specific.
We're not doing multiGPU today though
anyways. It is going in this version
Cashing allocator.
We'll
release to the end after all tensors are
cleared. Pools can't be released while
tensors captured still exist.
Okay,
does that make sense?
See, this feels awful because I
basically have [ __ ] all I can do here.
It's just undocumented PyTorch
internals.
Like, if I just have this in CUDA, it
would literally just be like Grap Cuda
Malik, right?
Pipe count.
Grapudafree pipe count. Oops, the
numbers don't match. and we'd be done.
I mean, this is just like checking
shenanigans.
I don't think you're going to get this.
Well, this might be a host error.
Might be a host error.
Hello Tim.
Tim has
Well, yeah, he committed all the map
files.
Easy and basic are the easy and basic
are generated
mainly bound by data stream transfer.
Not anymore because we have
optimizations for that. It's a pretty
flat profile like everything can be
optimized.
Static problem sets.
I can go look at the PR though for the
like the actual code file while I'm
waiting.
multi discrete
embedding is why it's going to be slow.
See,
this was probably annoying. No, that's
fine. That's not bad.
I don't know this probably loading of
maps during end is not great.
Yeah, that's going to be not great.
So I can look at but I like the main
thing is the is the end code good
my view
First pass. I don't see anything totally
stupid.
I don't see anything totally stupid.
Down.
Questionable.
Okay, that's questionable. I'll look at
that.
Step four.
Code does not look bad. I got to give it
a full review.
Let's figure this out in the meantime. I
mean, let's let's go back to doing this.
Okay, this is fine.
I didn't realize that could fail.
Be able to undo all this crap, of
course, if need be.
OBS is only 3.8
MB.
You know what? I want to try one other
thing which is I want to see
basically if I just SSH in
It's possible that it's torch being
weird.
Here's
That's interesting, right? Okay. We're
not actually
It might still be leaking. If it's
leaking only a little bit then.
No, cuz it just went back down in Alex
and then it went up.
I'm honestly I want to get this thing
out of my workflow.
I'm pretty much at this point I'm only
using it to deal with awful undocumented
torch [ __ ]
What the
Is it that dumb?
Literally doesn't realize.
Okay. Whatever.
Actually slowing you down. Uh to be fair
at the moment it is torch slowing me
down. Like torch just being garbage.
The internals of it.
I do think that this would like this
would not help me for a lot of the stuff
that I'm working on.
It makes you feel like you're doing
stuff faster, but you're really just
making a [ __ ] mess.
Yeah, I don't know. I got sleep.
I think I'm just sick of dealing with
torch. It's starting to get old.
Make sure that it's not that.
I think that does the same thing.
Is there anywhere else PieTorch should
have Alex? I don't think so. Right.
invalid device or argument. Are you
[ __ ] me?
doing leak code qualifies you to ruin a
uh to ruin
uh code bases on important problems.
That's about it.
It's just a very very bad representation
of actually what solving problems looks
like.
I mean like just pasting this into an
LLM is completely stupid waste of time,
right?
No, the thing is PyTorch allocates
intermediates
and you literally don't know what the
[ __ ] it's doing. That's the problem.
Isn't that um torch like siege stack
trace? Did you just add that to the
debug flags?
That's good. But the full I can merge
that, but the full debug equals one.
Like that also requires you to run with
CPU and stuff
to run with your stuff. Oh, okay. That's
nice. I will merge that.
This is not a sto a uh a torch like
crash though. Peru. Um
we're leaking memory and there's
basically no way for me to figure out
how because like torch does whatever the
hell Torch wants.
Check this out. Let's see what what you
link me.
Which me is held by which tensors?
With tensors you provide.
So, I mean, what would you recommend
that I do with this, man? Because the
issue I'm having here, right? Um,
I know for sure with cudggraphs on, it's
leaking memory because I can see it
running out over time over experiments.
I can't tell whether it is or not
without cudigraphs on. could just be
leaking more slowly across experiments.
It's hard to say. I can check my own
allocations, right? But like you
essentially have no idea what the heck
PyTorch does with intermediates. I
looked into trying to make the full
thing static. Uh the conclusion I came
to is if you want to make like Torch C++
API but static, you basically have to
throw out Torch at that point because
it's just not the way Torch is built.
is the out stuff. Yeah. So, I tried that
Peru. It doesn't work with um it doesn't
work with autograd
from what I saw.
Like you literally just have to throw
away torch.
ev values 10x more me than training did.
That's odd.
Some suggest embeddings. You can try
them, Jess.
pressure to tease that apart. Well, but
the thing is I don't know what the hell
is leaking, right?
Cuz like I'm running sweeps now, Peru.
So like from one training run to the
next
playing. That's so that's so rough.
I mean, this is the thing that pisses me
off is that this is just such a
manufactured problem, right? Like if I
just were writing my own library, it
would literally be like um grab
cudamalik pipe count and grap cudafree
pipe count and you're done.
So like me having to spend my time
[ __ ] with pietorches shitty
engineering is just not good. Like I
want to minimize this because I think
we're just going to replace torch um at
some point. Like this library has
consumed enough hundreds of hours of my
you know remaining year of my 20s. Thank
you very much.
Enough hours. It's not going to be
hundreds of hours this year. Screw that.
I'm not spending I'm not spending
hundreds of hours of the last year of my
20s dealing with Meta's absolute dog
[ __ ] engineering.
like I'm going to be doing I'm going to
be using this to solve RL. Um
Oh, hang on. Is this going to help us?
Yeah, this is going to help us.
So, here's the actual size of the leak,
right?
No, five will be go explore. We're not
doing half updates.
Eval run successfully.
Uh let me think. Could I try that?
I suppose I could try that.
cached workspaces.
Great. Let's just let let's just make
this thing super freaking slow.
Narrow down. Yeah, I can try that.
I guess it could technically be
evalu
But we shouldn't be memory bound, right?
Like there should be very very low
memory usage.
I mean like VRAM bound. Obviously the
ops are me bound.
I don't know if the gap is.
Yeah, it is slightly lower.
It's still leaking.
Are we leaking stuff on both then?
I don't think I'm even allocating
anything for um
for the backward here.
Not what I wanted to be doing today,
honestly. Like even the CUDA to C++
boundary with the launch functions I
think is a mistake.
And honestly, the entire thing should
just be like pufferlib.cu and we'd be
done.
Yeah. I mean, I think we like we could
write a simple sweep for that though,
right?
130, right?
Streams.
like torch aims to.
The problem is like whoop did you do?
You get to target your wide variety of
devices and use them at like 20%
efficiency or less
with smaller nets.
the buffer states and the streams are
the big two. I say
Not fun.
I think we fix this.
We see if we can fix graphs. Hopefully
this doesn't take terribly long. And
then we get um initial
constellation around
Okay. It's during training it allocates
a bunch of crap.
I'm not allocating a bunch of crap
though, so I don't know how
I don't think I'm allocating a bunch of
crap at the very least.
right
streams.
And then total is what?
722.
So about 150.
That's pretty close
for Eval. Could you replace most without
cre? I tried that. Peru. You basically
may as well delete Torch. Like you
completely break the model of Torch to
the point that the code's
unrecognizable.
So I think I will do that. But it's like
I messed with it for a few hours. It was
a disaster.
Okay, so this is what I thought. So this
is not actually leaking now
apparently.
Put cuda graphs on.
I This is just like awful.
It doesn't look like torch anymore.
Yeah.
I'm getting to the point where I'm just
really not enjoying my work anymore.
It's entirely because of torch,
which is not good because that always
tanks productivity.
All this shows that it's growing over
time with cudigraphs
I mean, couldn't you totally see just
like
forch should have just been like
um forch cu or whatever, right? that
just has a bunch of kernels that are
good that you can include.
It's so annoying. Like I can't even
tell.
Yeah, my brain is just like off right
now because it's just like I'm so bored
with this [ __ ] you know?
4 MB.
Yeah. So, it's up to 200 or whatever
with the graph.
And I the thing is I still think it's
leaking even without the stupid graphs
on.
I'm pretty sure it's still leaking.
Um, yeah. I mean, we have drones. We've
got like several like schooling type
environments.
You don't really need anything fancy
whatsoever for that.
There's like this unfinished version of
voids with puffer.
It's actually one of the better uses for
puffer because it's just tons of agents
and pretty simple networks and you can
get some very cool results.
I honestly think you can just drop our
standard network in you like you don't
really need to innovate anything there.
It's mostly just the environment and
having a reasonable reward and you're
good.
I'm actually just considering
having the hyper pram sweep just run
[ __ ] in a subprocess.
That's so bad though. Like I worked so
hard to not have to do that.
No, we can't do that. God, I just hate
this. This is like everything about this
is just awful.
It just puts you into this box where
there's like [ __ ] all you can do other
than bang your head against it till it
bleeds.
This is what happens when you have like
shitty enterprise frameworks that you're
stuck with.
Well, we need to at least get the train
function, right? I don't know why this
suddenly magically broke.
Yeah. Invalid device argument with no
trace.
I tried this with a C+ with the C++
stack trace. It just does not work.
I don't even understand how it's
possible that doesn't give you a trace,
Okay, here's our standalone with
presumably cudigraphs.
Okay. So, yeah, nothing is getting freed
until you call.
130 MB
match rollouts matches.
What's the difference?
250.
I'm just going to put train twice
to see if it what happens.
I mean, this is just so incredibly
disappointing that this is like this.
I mean, you just can't tell with this
though at Oh,
No. Apparently, it is a thing. I don't
know if it's the same thing as before.
Okay, hang on. There's 877 goes down to
835.
Yeah, you see that? So that actually
that freeze quite a bit.
Yes. Okay, good. There's no leaks.
Yeah, there are actually no leaks here.
God damn, that is annoying. Holy hell.
That is so obnoxious.
You literally can't even tell if you
have leaks.
Uh now unfortunately with the memory
caching thing.
Hang on.
Now we have to do this without the
freaking caching allocator
or with the without that flag with the
allocator.
Oh, actually look, it matches even here
with the workspace clears. So, this is
very good.
So, as long as we clear the Kublast
workspace
me close end.
This says no leaks.
Okay,
it looks like we can just free the
workspace.
I'm going to just let this run a bit
while I go get myself a cup of tea,
maybe grab myself a snack.
I think we have it fine now. I don't
know for sure, but I think we have it
fine.
I'll be right back, guys.
Okay.
Looks stable to me.
That's nice.
Man, that was irritating.
That was irritating.
Just the fact that it was such a pain to
figure out if stuff is even leaking at
all.
any tip on how to prevent overlapping
agents?
What do you mean overlapping agents?
Like how to prevent them from physically
colliding with each other?
It depends entirely on the environment.
You know,
sometimes it's as easy as just
partitioning stuff into a grid and only
letting one thing be per grid cell.
If you have continuous space, then you
partition stuff into chunks and you only
check the current chunk and adjacent
chunks.
As long as things don't group up a ton,
like you can do this stuff pretty
efficiently.
continuous space, then you're going to
want to chunk it.
I mean, it depends how many agents,
right? If you have a couple hundred
agents, you can actually get away with
just doing it in a loop naively.
Um, if you have thousands, then you'd
use chunks.
chunks. No. So you have So by chunks
it's what you like you what instead of
checking all possible pairs, right? You
split the space up into chunks and then
you only check collisions within those
chunks. So that's how you do that
quickly.
all the collisions I have to run
multiple iterations to resolve
what type of collisions are you doing
right
like do you have complex collision
geometry or is it just spheres because
if it's spheres it's really easy if you
can do it with bounding spheres it's
really Easy.
What end are you building? Oh, yeah.
Any penalty?
Not really efficient to do penalty. I
mean you can kind you end up doing both
is the thing like they get penalized for
colliding to some extent and then you
disallow the collisions in the code.
right.
All right. I need something funny after
dealing with this crap. That was
Thank you. Yes. And that very much
delivered
after dis displacing each pair.
See, you don't need to like displace
them. You just disallow them from
colliding. Like when it moves, if it's
going to collide, don't do that. It's
that easy.
Yeah, I
That's pretty funny.
That is pretty funny.
Let's get a few experiments out of this.
Oops. Actually, hang on. We can do
That's smart. Yeah,
I mean very small changes like this will
make a massive difference
in uh
if stuff is fast or not.
Then like boom, you no longer need that
entire chunk of code and all that wasted
compute, right?
It just works.
Oh, these don't have memes on them
anymore, do they?
Set it to seven. We set to seven.
56 to like
seven maybe. No. Yeah, we can do this.
Okay, cool. Let's see if this does
anything.
We'll give it a few more of these
experiments.
And then we'll try it with breakout
after
Let's see if we get um
at least a few reasonable experiments
out of this. We can play with
constellation
It does not seem to be finding good um
good configs which is kind of weird.
It is a very large search space I
suppose.
But we should definitely have this
working.
Well, I mean, this is the full search
space, so
presumably we can prune chunks of it,
but that's one of the objectives of
constellation. Oh, there you go. I mean,
that was some signal at the very least.
So now presumably there's some numerical
instability with Bflat. There's some
numerical instability from kernels.
We're not going to get amazing sweeps
out of everything just yet.
That is real learning though right there
from like whatever params it just chose.
We did get kind of lucky I would say
then with the uh the current breakout
setup that we were able to maintain
perf uh and keep it stable.
But now we can do stuff like sweep B
float versus float 32.
And we can do lots of stuff.
And we can actually we can do that on WB
and we can do it on constellation both.
I think I should probably what I should
do is let's let this run a few more so
that we have them for constellation to
play with and then um
what I can do is I can just see if I
have the wii integration set up and then
I can hopefully have this thing stable
enough
or uh contributors to play around with.
And I can start running experiments
myself as well, which is nice.
I mean, it is normal that it takes a
couple dozen runs sometimes to even pick
any signal up. So, that plus instability
plus all the other stuff. Yeah, I think
that's fine.
Let's just kill off some old R because
we don't need any of this
hidden size. layers expansion factor.
So there's no layers. Yep, that's the
same.
We're good.
And we're perfectly set. Yeah. Oh, there
it was. That was a That was a good run,
wasn't it? Yeah. Cool. So, that'll give
us some uh some data.
doing 3 second runs for some reason.
Had 18 million steps per second with
tiny little networks.
They actually learned a little bit with
a 40k perm network is funny. 10k param
network.
Okay, maybe it should not be able to run
10,000 parameter networks.
All right, maybe we're going to cap this
64 smallest.
Shoot. That's actually did pretty well
with a
Well, we'll be able to compare nicely
either way.
Yep, there's the dot there. So, we only
have a few good runs
and should be a lot more bad runs
though,
There we are. That's a few more points,
right?
So, I mean, there's not really a need
for us to run uh this entire thing.
I do think we probably want to have this
thing set up with W to be
And if this works, then we pretty much
have sweeps integration.
I do kind of like the idea of also
saving the wampy runs to uh local
failed.
Why failed?
No. Okay. Log cost. Long pause
Sudoku would be actually ask Weston. I'm
pretty sure Weston did Sudoku
the Discord. It's Tanky Chopper in the
Discord actually. I think his name is
MultiGPU sweeps. MultiGPU sweeps are
actually quite easy to do. Substantially
easier than multiGPU like single runs
are. So that will be done before
uh before
multiGPU single runs are.
This is nice.
So, let's just uh status
Well, we now have some basic sweeps
testing.
Yeah, you can actually right click all
the points which is kind of cool.
Much left to be done. Much much left to
be done.
It's 400 p.m.
I could try the multiGPU sweep stuff.
over wand bay. Uh go ahead and try to
load up like 4,000 experiments in wand.
See if it works.
So this thing I will be able to load up
sweep data across all the environments
in aggregate like 10,000 plus runs
and like we will have all sorts of stats
instantly. It's just way better for
large scale aggregate monitoring.
You pretty much have the same interface
where you have custom plots, you've got
extras,
you've got hyperparam stability regions.
This is not filled in yet, but this will
be a tene.
I don't know, Jess, if you ever saw the
original version of constellation with
like uh with a bunch of data loaded in.
It looks really freaking sweet
when you have a bunch of data loaded in.
And obviously still needs some polish.
It's not fully done.
constellation. No, not another client.
This is part of um part of puffer 40.
It's our hyperf visualizer that's
written in C. So we just have our own
standalone like visualizer for data.
It's like our version of like our
wannabe or whatever though it's for
something a little different.
Hey Tim.
Uh the data down here is just dummy. But
then up here, this is like a few runs of
40 O data actually loaded into
constellation. So this is like the what
is this? 7 seconds or whatever to solve
loaded in
Tim. I'm mostly just exhausted from
having dealt with PieTorch so much. Like
I really don't want to have PyTorch be a
thing. Um, we have to keep it for now,
but
I like I don't really want to spend much
more time fighting torch.
Hyper pram. Yeah. So you can look this
is cost versus score. So I can do clip
coefficient versus score. I can do mini
batch size versus score. I can do
whatever I want versus score. And like
you can do this in wannabe as well, but
it'll lag. And if you try to put 5,000
points, it'll say, "Haha, are you
kidding me? What do you think we are? An
assa supercomputer." So here you just
have whatever points you want. Um you
can just like plot stuff instantly and
this will handle thousands of points.
And you can see here there's an all
option. when you have multiple M's, you
can just click what NV you want from the
drop down or you can click all and have
all the M's at once.
So I it's just like, hey, what if data
viz weren't super slow and we could do
aggregate viz over a ton of M's like at
the same time? And then the other reason
I wrote this is because I wanted to do
uh benchmarks, full sweeps for every
Env.
So like this will live on the website
with all of the data from all the sweeps
loaded in for 40. So you will have the
highest performance, biggest set of
experiments ever run in RL
and it'll just like have all the
aggregate data in your browser
stable hyper range. Yeah, that's down
here. It's not very interesting with
just one env and a few data points, but
it's here.
Okay. Um,
there are a few things I'd like to do at
the moment, I think. Yeah, there are a
few things I would like to do.
Let's just real quick, let's see if we
can figure out some stability.
Yeah, Jess, it would extend like it
would be at least another couple months
of dev to fully rip out PieTorch.
Okay. So, in order to get this thing to
train, this thing needs to not have
portals and VF-16.
If I do this,
I I do wonder if these go hand in hand
though because like one of the big
things about having our custom kernels
is that we don't end up uh casting to
BF-16 so many times for intermediaries.
Get this SPS. Oh, this is nothing. Tim,
this is nothing. You want SPS
Puffer train. Puffer breakout. Don't
blink.
There you go. 7 seconds. Breakout
solved.
Yeah. 14 mil.
Usually about 14.
I honestly think we can probably have
even go a fair bit faster without torch,
but we're stuck with torch for now.
It is unfortunately. It's genuinely the
case here. Wait, how fast is this?
12 mil, 13 mil.
Yeah. Okay. So I mean that's the speed
that you expect.
But then why are our kernels unstable?
Just see if it's like a silly little
thing here.
If I just like lower
probably six.
No breakout's usually the simplest end
that's still meaningful.
Is it just doing multi-discreet wrong?
What is another multi-discrete n?
What's the hardest end maze?
Uh,
I mean, neural MMO is really hard. I
guess the driving like the larger scale
configs of driving are pretty tough and
then like mazes you can make arbitrarily
hard, but it's it's only meaningful for
certain types of things, right? Like
mazes are an environment that you pull
out for a specific type of benchmark.
Let's not embarrass myself bothering
Jonah when uh maybe I'm just dumb here.
Okay, so this starts training instantly,
right?
What happens if I have custom kernels
on?
Okay, so maybe just BF-16 without
kernels is bad.
Let me test one other thing. Let's not
be like stupid here.
Oh yeah, it'll be very good.
Soon will be nice.
It'll be like in the same sort of
category as the maze. Well, we'll use it
for mainly like the algorithms research,
BF16 not stable without custom kernels.
Custom kernel not stable
We'll just have this do quick check in
case it's dumb and easy.
And if not,
we'll sort it from there.
And I'm going to start looking for it at
the same time.
I wouldn't be surprised. It's some
striding [ __ ]
Uh, there's no way this can possibly be
correct, is there?
Or where do we get numb actions from?
Actually, maybe it is.
Okay. Well, this takes a bunch of
strides.
I'm a bit suspicious of this.
We are passing stream, right?
Yeah, we are passing stream. Nice. This
is forward only. That makes it a little
easier.
Rose stride maybe some
of act sizes for fused output.
I think that's like an easy thing to
check.
okay I mean this is easy for us to check
right
I would believe That
did I not merge this fix? I thought I
had merged this fix.
Didn't Isn't this actually what Jonah
fixed?
Let's try false
python
build
in place
And then if this works, this should make
puffer work on a lot more M's.
Aha.
Ho ho ho ho.
Okay, that's super sweet. So, all we got
to do
is go check if I've been a donut and if
I have a PR open for this.
Sweeping none of 10 minutes. You
literally can do that for P.
How's your SP3 going at the house?
Yeah.
That's
that. I think it will not screw up.
That's like changing two loops, right?
I should check this one though. This one
is like bad to mess up.
And then we have our Perf benchmarks.
Actually,
then if this is like BF-16 is
numerically stable, that's really
freaking good for us, isn't it?
Yeah, that's not too bad of a difference
because it's just the thumb
and the entropy as well.
Yeah, it's not bad.
Might be a little weird for backward. I
don't know.
I don't think it should be.
No, I this is I think this is a like a
straightforward enough fix that this
thing will just do it.
It's essentially adding a for loop here.
It's very easy to screw up is the thing.
It is very easy to screw up here and
here.
And then the launch functions and the
module bindings and the torch bindings
and all that crap.
This also here
this being commented is sketch.
I think this being commented is very
sketch.
I'm gonna have to double check that.
We'll say this is what we'll work on
today. That way we can run um we should
be able to start running some
basic sweeps
and we should actually have it be so
that um we save uh logs also locally.
We'll just do that. That's easy enough.
Now, this ought to last for a while,
though, because I'm not using it
anywhere near as much.
There is still some refactor that will
have to be. It's like AI having to clean
up AI slop. So, whatever.
Proceed thing.
Let me go look at this in the meantime
as I do think that this is a little
screwy.
Yeah, we do not update. We do not update
the ratio, do we?
MB ratio. Yeah, this does not get
updated.
Okay, we will we will play with that
then.
Well, we found one thing that I
definitely messed with in the
implementation that we should probably
fix.
I forget if it messed up graphing. It
shouldn't.
I mean, I'll be able to mess with that
though.
That could very well be the thing that's
screwing up our trainle.
accumulated values.
Okay, let's actually see what this is.
Well, amaz what do you mean? Is this
complexity type quantifiable? So, Jess,
um it's a pure exploration task.
So there are
there are al algorithmic improvements
that you would expect to make the method
better on mazes and then there are
algorithmic improvements you would not
expect uh to make better on mazes.
Mazes are very good because if you know
what you're studying they transfer
incredibly well to a wide class of
problems. But like
so the basic understanding of RL right
is we have a bunch of environments and
some are easy and some are hard and if
we make our algorithms better on all the
environments then our algorithms are
probably better everywhere. So we
advance the field right?
If we want to be a bit more precise, we
can kind of use different environments
to study different subpros of learning
and mazes cover a couple of those
different subpros depending on how you
set them up. So like there are specific
types of algorithmic improvements where
mazes are a very good benchmark because
they isolate the one thing you're
studying and then there are certain
classes of algorithmic improvements
where they don't. For Puffer 5, for
instance, we expect that we're going to
be heavily using uh mazes and then if
Tim finishes Soabon, that'll also be a
great end for it.
We actually don't expect Puffer 5 to
make a dramatic difference on say
Breakout for instance, though it might,
but we don't expect it to.
exploration. Yes, except that it's you
can't just say exploration because that
itself is poorly defined.
There are definitely measures, but like
they're kind of difficult to explain.
Let me sort of try to give you a little
bit of the basics here. So mazes are
cool because uh you can learn an agent
that learns the exploration strategy for
mazes itself. So you can have it train
on a bunch of mazes and try to solve a
new unsolved maze more quickly by having
learned a good exploration strategy. You
can use mazes as sparse reward problems
where you have a really big maze and you
just see how long it takes your
algorithm to get to the end.
And those two things are very different.
So you kind of have two separate ways
you can use mazes. And then improving on
either of those subtasks is going to
correlate to improving performance on
other tasks at least somewhat
predictably.
How does maze solve a maze? Isn't it
just BFS? Yes. So you can absolutely
just solve the maze in like four lines
of code or what is it 10 lines of code
with BFS. Um that's not the point,
right?
Because the thing is the RL can solve
other problems that you can't solve with
BFS and that doesn't make it a bad
benchmark.
It's It's kind of funny that this thing
can do I think that this is correct that
it can do kernel logic
but it can't do like cuz this is
actually relatively hard
Launchers. It can totally do. Launchers.
It's I'm not worried about. That's
actually what it's for. I'm more worried
about the logic.
Uh,
hang on. That's
upper limits.
That's good.
That was also probably screwing it up
then.
This is the chunk that's mostly like
ain't nobody want to edit that.
It will be interesting though if we have
if we actually even end up needing the
float path.
It's a bit annoying because like if you
ever have numerical instability, you
kind of want to have the flow path.
I have not written any articles or
anything lately.
Probably need to do that.
Well,
we'll see whether I get burned for this
or not.
To be clear, I don't mean for updating
the module logic like this. The module
logic should absolutely be done this way
because like this is just a bunch of
boiler boiler plate garbage from Torch.
Uh if I were to write my own library,
none of this would even exist.
It's mostly the kernel that I could get
burned on.
I did check those ones way more
carefully.
But that one I will admit I could
totally have screwed up.
Only deal with one stupid torch thing
for today. And today it was the memory.
The
caller just needs to passes. It's
The caller just needs to passes. It's easy enough.
easy enough.
And that's static, so it should work
with photographs,
not exposed.
We're fine.
And then if this works,
I should now be able to train
with B float and custom kernels.
That actually probably fixes a bunch of
stuff for us. Like that's probably why a
lot of our stuff was jank.
We should still probably run like the
optimized uh the tuned versions with
custom kernels and without.
But yeah, this is good. This is exactly
what we want. Perfect.
Okay.
How can RL learn which way to explore if
they're randomly generated?
Um, so the idea, right, Calamaria, is
like you can do stuff like always follow
the left wall. You can do stuff like
uh like remembering which branches
you've taken and like exploring new
ones.
Random exploration is very very very bad
at mazes. Like exponentially bad. So you
can't really do better than quadratic on
mazes. You do kind of just have to
explore the whole thing. But that's a
hell of a lot better than exponential.
So you can still learn. There's a lot
that you can still learn on mazes. And
the goal would be that you learn
something that approaches uh not BFS
because BFS is not an algorithm that you
can actually run in practice but like
DFS. It should be uh it should be
comparable to DFS if you optimize well.
And if the if the goal is always in the
same spot, then it should be comparable
more
not exactly to a star but kind of.
Okay.
Well, this is super nice. Um
I think we just like go run some
environments, right?
because a lot of the stuff that didn't
work before should now just work.
Here's the restroom real quick and then
we'll see what I can do with this.
Why is BFS not feasible? Well, in Mazes
it is. The point though is like the
point isn't that yay now we can solve
mazes that's so important right
just because it happens to be that in
maze like here for instance I could swap
the mazes to be in continuous space and
the RL would work just the same
but your BFS wouldn't now yeah you could
discretize it right but the point is I
can just go get harder problems and the
RL works and mazes don't and it used to
be case that maybe the RL worked in
theory, but it actually didn't. Now the
RL actually works. So there you have it.
Let's see if we can get some basic stuff
done on um it's like our basic configs.
You don't need to have BF16 off.
Okay, let's get rid of this off. This is
silly.
algorithmic improvements beyond
Well, there there are a few different
topics within exploration just that
matter at the moment.
One is based on state sets. Another is
based on um
like obser like novelty and observations
we learn from Mar. Yeah. Well, what it
means, Calamaria, is the algorithmic
improvements that we make here let us
take the exact same training code and
chuck it on harder problems and it just
works.
Like I've done very little work on these
individual environments trying to get RL
to solve these all these individual
tasks and like as we do more on the core
of puffer lib we need less and less work
for every new problem we want to solve.
Okay. So, we have different params here,
right?
This is supposed to be
Yeah. See, we have very different
parameters here. So, let's just take
these.
Let's put them into here real quick.
like this.
This is supposed to be eight,
right? And then this is supposed to be
total agents. Whoops. Toad.
No, false.
Uh, BF16
false.
Don't think this does it either.
Just to see if these are good in any
event.
No, that does not seem particularly
useful now, does it?
Okay.
What happens? I got a question, right?
Here's the question. What happens if I
do this?
What if I do this one now?
Let's go down the line.
Well, now I have a question. Is if I do
this, does this make it worse?
Nope.
In fact, it looks more stable to me.
So there's not the difference in those
custom kernels then.
No, we have it right here. There's the
ratio.
This is not done in the kernel.
That's fine.
It's at least a decent starting point, I
would think. Right.
Oh, you know the one that I want to
check is this one here.
What was this? Like 500k
this 500k SPS config. I wonder if this
one works.
This was I have to go back a whole bunch
of commits to see where this was from.
But I want to see if this works.
512. Okay,
let's see what happens if I do this.
Uh, okay. So, that's an issue because
that's really fast and we don't get any
logs.
The mini batches is eight.
I think that makes sense.
I can't understand how Popper gets
better at solving hard problems.
I understand about PO mini. What do you
mean you understand about PO mini
batches?
You don't understand how we take the
baseline most successful algorithm in
the field
which has not been extensively evaluated
on a ton of different environments
because everybody's implementations are
very slow. We crowdsource develop a ton
of environments.
We test our implementation and fix
little things here and there on that. We
make it faster and faster so we can have
more and more stable and robust tests
and then we do a little bit of research
and we find a few changes to PO that
actually work broadly across all the
environments. Like
you don't understand how that loop
works. That seems like a pretty like
pretty solid recipe. Now
Why do we not get logs back from this
thing?
Are we just not printing the dashboard?
I'll clear here.
Oh, I know what it is.
There we go. This is why everything's
been screwy.
It doesn't learn.
At least we fix the log bug though.
I tried to implement with many batches
proper OBS actions all just break out.
It's not easy to get results. No, it
isn't. It's not easy at all.
This is why it's like, oh, it's so easy,
right? It's just like a couple hundred
lines of code. Here, I'm going to go do
that right now. Like, a number of people
have tried to do that and failed. That's
expected, dude. This is literally, if
you read my guide, my guide tells you
explicitly not to do that because you're
going to not like it's not going to work
and you're going to feel really stupid,
dude. I could not just sit down and
implement PO and have it work correctly
within a few hours.
It's like RL is not that way. That
doesn't work that way, dude. You should
not feel bad about that.
All right, so this was probably some
super brittle thing. But hey, at the
very least, what we get to do with this,
I'm relieved.
Did you read my guide? Because my guide
did warn you of this.
I don't even know what PO is. If you
want to learn, we have all the resources
around for you.
All right. Well, this is stupid, but
this is a perfect solve. So, I guess
we'll just say, yay, we have Pong.
I read one guy,
one guy of you. Not the long one. One
guide, I imagine. Yeah, I only have two
guides, right? My general one and then
my long RL one. It has all of my best
advice in one place. There's literally
not a more efficient way to learn RL out
there. If you follow that guide, you
will learn RL. It's that
straightforward.
Not solving cart pole.
Not ideal.
Okay. Well, we can fix that real quick.
Hang on.
Not the rigorous math.
Uh my guides are not very math
intensive. Have you se like here? Look.
All right. I'll show you what I have.
This is this is how I suggest people
learn RL.
this guy. It's not a short read, but
it's not really a super long read
either. Uh, it's also interactive. Like,
you don't just read this and you learn
RL. You have to do the stuff that the
guide says. So, like build a simple
environment and train an agent here.
This is a link. Now, read this. Now, do
that. Write your own M. Ask your stuff.
Read this blog. Now, read this section.
Now, read and train this environment.
Okay, cool. Now you've done this. Now
make something like this about this
complexity. Read these code. Read this
code.
Add this to your own code.
Here is when I have you read the um a
chunk of the PO stuff. Like you read a
couple bullets, then you read the PO
paper or at least most of it.
And this is literally right here. Hey
Liberty, this would have prevented you
from h from doing that. Understand why I
didn't have you implement the algorithm
This is a list of papers. They're only
like 10 of them. You don't have to read
all of them right up front. You can read
those over time. Bunch of advice, some
stuff on apps.
some stuff on algorithms.
Boom.
So,
good luck.
Damn. Yep.
Yeah, that's I told you so.
Unfortunately,
Okay. It's a little silly, but like
if you just train for 50 mil steps.
Was it unstable?
It is unstable.
Can I just like Yes.
That's funny.
This ought to be a real easy
environment.
Failing to solve cartpole is um
definitely an interesting one.
Did somebody PR a fix to carpole that
was not a fix?
Did I goober this? No, I didn't.
How'd this happen?
horse mag.
It's actually there's a lot of stuff in
here. We're not um
Yeah. What the heck? D
Oh, wait. That's just DT.
Full mass cart mass full length gravity
force
Okay.
That's a weird one. It's definitely a
weird one.
Okay. So, what is wrong with cart pole?
Not a question I thought I'd have to
ask.
Okay, so that is correct. Fine. Uh, did
I copy params over wrong?
No,
that's weird then. I don't know why that
happens. I did get a PR though for the
dynamics being jank. So, I'm going to
leave that alone for now.
I renamed a bunch of parameters like a
goober.
Cool.
Did I do any of these? Uh, these ones
should have been the same though.
Four. Trash pickup.
We can just do trash pickup real quick.
Trash.
We know ourware seg faults for whatever
dumb reason
has num agent.
Well, no other parameters.
Um, yeah, this is the wrong
Hang on. This the wrong thing.
Not great.
Okay, so we definitely then still have
some screwy stuff going on.
Triple triad
Definitely more stable than we had
before.
Oh, interesting. Hang on.
Is there some total agents bug? Because
that
No, it's just screwy.
But I remember this having a different
config like
Really?
How does this not have a lower gamma on
it or something? At least
that doesn't make sense. If I like if I
literally gamma is 0.95 or whatever,
does this not just work?
Yeah.
Okay. Okay. Well, I don't know why the
heck that wasn't there,
but yeah, this doesn't need to.
I can literally just do this.
This will work
Let's try Blast Star. Blast Star is
sketchy.
Freeway 2048 Pac-Man.
Let me go try Pac-Man.
cuz I remember it was stuck at like 109
or whatever.
So that's fine. That runs
Retraining six mil SPS, 8 mil SPS. Why
is it getting faster and faster? Isn't
that sketchy?
Oh, it's cuz it's not resetting as
frequently. That's funny.
That's way faster than we used to be
able to train. So that's sweet.
Numb layers one should not be one. This
should be four.
So this is not going to be the same. Um
well let me see.
Let's actually go check. Uh, it's it's
in 3 0, right?
256 hidden. Oh, that's 61 lines deleted.
Holy.
Let's just do numbum layers four.
Yeah. So this is this should be the fair
comparison.
We can get rid of these params. These
are no longer a thing.
These are no longer a thing. We just get
rid of this.
Okay. 65
lines.
Come on.
Train me some policy.
Uh that is still a 849K environment
running 5 plus mil SPS which is kind of
cool
but it's just not catching on to the
reward one bit.
Kind of weird that it worked with one
layer.
Yeah, it catches on with one layer.
That's funny.
Endura we just make sure
works
I mean, this is learning,
right?
Logs are just super infrequent. Yeah,
this is learning. We're good.
Takes forever.
Uh, popper convert.
Maybe not. I don't remember if they can
see each other.
Oh yeah, they apparently they can see
each other. So that makes un slow.
Episode length decreasing is good. Works
as intended.
Uh, we have Snake. Snake has been
sketchy.
Snake has been sketchy lately. Let's see
if our magic changes fix everything or
not.
So, what do we have? End of num 8. So,
we have vec total agents
4096. We get rid of num ms.
We update the parameter names and we see
if suddenly snake is no longer weird.
It's still weird and unstable, man.
Yeah, I don't know.
This num mini batches thing is kind of
weird. Hang on. Let me look at this.
Oh, no. That's normal for 4096 agents,
right?
Yeah, that's normal.
I don't know why this param is literally
zero. That's like super odd.
One last thing.
What happens if I do this?
Or actually two last things real quick.
So like let's try something.
First step is we do this.
I'm trying to remember if this was able
to get to 100 plus before. I think this
does get to 100 plus in 300.
It does look like it's not the
environment being super jank though.
Yeah, maybe puffer three just found some
wacky hypers. I don't know.
This is not bad perk. I don't even
remember if we have the snake encoder or
not in puffer.
We do.
I don't think it's the good snake
encoder though. It's like the dumb snake
encoder. This is fine. Yeah. So, it's I
mean, Puffer is pretty stable. It's
literally just the um some of the
individual configs.
Go.
We'll go needs a custom net. Hang on.
Drone is continuous.
Custom net. Custom net.
Everything else is custom net. Hasn't
been ported.
I do want to see real quick with neural
MMO
agents or total agents.
Total agents 4096.
mini badge size. Go away with this.
batch size can go away.
Oh, wait. Is that
That batch size is kind of suspicious,
isn't it? Cuz it's 4096.
What happened
in place or dummy?
Oh, wait. That's a quite large network.
That's a quite large network. 4.4 mil.
Okay, that makes sense. Then
that can get swept over though.
It'd be interesting if now we have
something that just like know that
learns way better quickly or something.
I mean, that episode length is good.
combat level. It's got a few agents that
are getting some combat experience.
Nobody's figured out how to get um items
yet. The profession level is zero.
And this would take what? Two days to
train 100 belt.
the current params.
I think we can do better,
but it's not a bad start.
You do actually get some learning signal
immediately in the sense that the
episode length is increasing, right?
Oh, you know one thing I actually I want
to try now.
There is actually one thing I want to
try.
What happens if we throw defaults at
this?
You know
what just happens if I comment
everything?
Are we magically smart?
What's our default at?
And
like are we just magically smart if we
do this?
Actually, we'll give it the full
complement of
192.
Okay. It shouldn't be slower. That's not
a thing that should happen.
Oh, look at that F length.
Holy crap. Look at that.
We are actually learning immediately.
You see that
though? What are we learning to do? like
the combat level
is zero.
So, you're mostly just learning to walk
around and not die.
What smart thing did you do? What smart
thing?
I don't know if I've done any smart
things today.
I wonder if there's something to it like
just not wanting to risk anything at all
because it's not like it's not getting
any combat.
There's probably just some dynamic here
I'm like not understanding.
Look at the tiny little network. Boom.
Episode length instantly going up.
Oh.
Oh, look guys. Look at that.
It's learning to fight a little bit in
one minute
with the tiny little network.
Oh, we're going to have fun sweeping
this environment.
I do think that the cool thing though is
we can probably run a much shorter sweep
on this.
3 minutes is what? Yeah, we can probably
run a much shorter sweep on this
and get something now.
Wait, was that I think that was like
little 0.01's in the prof level
or did I say that wrong? I saw a couple
in sales.
Mincom prof. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It
is.
So, I think basically we can get excited
that um
we probably are going to be able to
sweep this
and have it at least learn something in
like 500 mil.
We'll see
enough of this. Um I do want to figure
out
What's going on with this?
I should be able to do
like does it need eight buffers or
something?
Is it too big?
maybe.
No, I'm just messing with some M's. Just
like playing with puffer, seeing at the
wood stable
Wonder if it is the end of bandwidth at
this point then.
62% timing forward.
Two buffers by two buffers.
Even slower.
Uh oh.
I just want to try one last ridiculous
thing just to see.
fast DNS.
We should probably play with those now
that we have um like the efficient
our efficient backends.
Oh yeah, you know the one other thing I
think that this disabled KUDNN
optimizations
set bench? No, benchmark is true.
So, this is fine.
Well, that's all the nets we have um
encoders for. I think it's going to be
Let's make some commits real quick and
then I know what I got to set up.
Uh, so Jess, the thing is that in Puffer
4, you can stack the recurrent cell
deeper. So there's going to be like
there multiple options you have
available. It's not just like you have
to stack encoder.
Okay, let's make sure that this is
stable
and then we will uh we'll let this just
run while I have dinner.
Oh yeah, wannie is actually now it's
pretty swift. So it's wellness good.
with this interval.
It's probably this.
Nope.
Are we broken?
That thing is Come on.
Yay, it runs.
CNN for images. CNN is for
uh 2D spatial inputs.
So,
chess is a 2D board.
The point of CNN is to tell the network
that this thing close to each other,
like this thing that's near this other
thing, probably matters than this more
than this thing that's over there,
which can be good or bad.
Okay. Um, this seems to run.
I think I'm just going to leave this
here, detach,
and um, we're going to see what happens.
And we get to start on the loop where we
run lots of experiments a little bit,
but we also have to fix up lots and lots
of stuff left in uh in Puffer. But we
have the end to end. And I would say
that this counts as a pre-alpha.
So
it's pretty much pre-alpha ready. You
can go download it. You can play with
it. The docs are not updated yet. So you
have to do setup.py pie build env.
But that's pretty much it.
I am going to go get some food. I may or
may not do an evening stream. We shall
see.
To be determined.
If you'd like to support my work for
absolutely free, puffer fish like stars.
Fun fact, feed this one a star on GitHub
to help me out. Uh, you can join Discord
to get involved with dev and you can
follow me on X for more RL content. I
will be back probably a little bit
tomorrow, definitely Thursday, maybe
even later tonight. Thank you all. Have
a nice evening.